- We need to adjust our
mentality for ourselves
and our leaders.
Like, you know, it's been
this way for most of my life,
where the right, when it comes
to something like a boycott,
it was the norm, Dave,
it was mainstream.
Not just from politicians,
from pundits to say things,
like, "Well, we don't do
that, that's not who we are.
Well, that's not who we are."
And then we woke up one day,
and Target's telling
your 13-year-old daughter
to chop her boobs off, and
we were shocked at that.
Well, why were we
shocked at that?
The corporate boardroom was
only ever getting pressure
from one direction.
The right has to understand now
that this whole
philosophy of bragging
about not using
power is ridiculous.
If you have the
governorship, like DeSantis,
you use it like DeSantis.
If you have numbers in
your local community,
you go take over
your school board,
and you make sure your
values are in your school.
You use power.
The communist is
still a minority,
but he understands
how to use power.
We will drive by the local
public library 1,000 times,
you, me, everybody, and
you won't even look at it
unless you have kids.
It's a public library,
who gives a crap about it.
The communist drives
by the public library,
and he sees an
opportunity, he sees power.
Why are there child
drag shows going on
at your local public library?
Because you drove
by it 1,000 times,
and never thought about it,
and he drove by it
and he saw power.
That's why we must
adjust our mentality.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the author of "The
Anti-Communist Manifesto,"
as well as the host of
"The Jesse Kelly Show."
Jesse Kelly, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Dave, it is an honor to be
here once again, my friend,
as always, Dave.
Yes, I'm a world-famous
author now, Dave.
I'm a very important person now.
- (laughing) Is this
your first book?
- It is my first book, and
will probably be my only book.
The truth is I
don't like to write.
I enjoy doing TV and radio,
that's what I do for a living.
But I don't enjoy writing.
I just, they were hounding
me, hounding me, hounding me,
"Hey, we want you to write
a book," for a few years.
And I always just said,
"No," I wasn't interested.
And then they said, "What
if you wrote something
about anti-communism,"
'cause that's what I'm
most passionate about.
And I said, "Yes,
that I will write."
So this is my one-off
probably, but I am proud of it.
- Before we get into the
specifics of the book,
and the political machinations,
and all of the
lunacy of the day,
I wanna talk about your height,
because you're like
8'7" or something.
And every time I see
you in real life,
despite the fact
that I've seen you,
I don't know, probably a
dozen times in reality,
because you're in a
small box right now,
you seem normal size, but
in real, you're 6'8", right?
Like, you're huge, man.
You should be in the NBA,
and instead you're
babbling about politics
with schmucks like me.
- Okay, hold on, yes, I'm 6'8",
but I'm also unathletic, Dave.
I'm slow, I can't jump,
I'm not coordinated.
So those things always-
- Have you thought
about the WNBA?
- (laughing) They put a ceiling
on my athletic
achievements, that's one.
Two, you think I'm tall,
and that hits you
when you meet me,
and I always get
this from people,
"Oh, I can't believe
I'll tall you are,
I didn't realize that."
You know, what hits me, Dave?
How short everyone else
is that I see on TV,
or something like
that, when you meet,
because everyone on
TV, in my opinion,
looks like they're a good size.
He takes up the
whole screen, right?
So you think, now, by
the way, Dave Rubin,
for those who've never met
him, is tall, I would guess
you're at least six feet.
- Thank you.
- But so many people I meet
are just minuscule, Dave.
I'll walk up to
them, and I'm used to
this larger-than-life
personality,
and I feel like patting
him on the head,
and getting him a
binky or something.
- (laughing) All right,
well, beyond your height,
one of the reasons I
love doing your show,
and that, you know,
we're kinda in the same
circles these days,
is 'cause I think we both have
a similar attitude
about politics.
It's like we talk
about politics, we're
passionate about it,
but we're also
trying to have fun.
We're trying to make
our audience laugh,
and not, you know,
so many people are just
riling these people up,
and then sending them
out into the world.
When did you get
involved in politics,
or interested in politics,
or any version of like
what that was about you
that made you wanna do this
the way that you do it?
- Pretty late in life, which
probably explains a lot,
including what you were
just talking about,
I always loved history,
I was always a reader.
Now I was a very bad student,
I got a 0.0 in my first
semester of college,
that's real by the way,
I was a very bad student,
but I-
- How, wait, is that possible?
How's that even possible?
- Well Dave, there's
beer, and there's girls,
and as long as there's
plenty of that around,
you don't ever end up in class,
I figured out, if no one's
there to make you go.
So it was a very fun semester,
but not the most productive
one in the world.
Anyway, but I didn't get
political until late in life.
I grew up in a construction
family, that's my background.
Joined the Marines,
got out of the Marines,
started going to
community college,
right back to construction,
that's just what I was gonna do.
And then Obama ran for office,
and I ended up
running for Congress,
'cause I was so mad about
him running for office
a couple times in Arizona.
Ended up staying in the fight,
going back to the private
sector, selling RVs.
So I've only been
doing like TV and radio
four or five years.
But you're right, I'm
on the same philosophy.
I mean, I did it
in the book too.
I do it on my radio show.
I do it on my TV show,
just like you do.
I don't like to scream
and yell all day long.
There's enough bad
news out there.
And we talk about
that very frankly,
but screaming and yelling,
and my blood pressure's
going through the roof,
that I'm upset and you're upset.
And then that's just,
there's way too much of that.
I don't like it.
- What was it that you
saw about Obama early on
that probably, I suppose,
led to a guy like you
writing a book like this?
- Well, again, I wasn't, I
always knew we were Republican,
but that was one
conversation with my parents.
I think I was in kindergarten.
"Hey Dad, are we
Democrat or Republican?"
"We're Republican."
I didn't even know
why, just, "Oh, okay."
So it wasn't a political house,
but it was a patriotic house.
And I mentioned that I
was reading all the time.
I was a geek for military
history, and military fiction,
and military anything
when I was a kid,
just gimme a book on the
Marines and let me read it.
So I really was raised
with a deep, deep
love of the country.
And while I never really
cared honestly about Clinton,
and a lot of these guys, I
knew all the controversies.
Obama was the first guy I
saw running for president
that I really, I could tell
he really hates the country.
He really, really
hated the country.
And I was so aghast
at the thought of,
'cause I guess I probably had
lofty ideals back then, Dave.
I was a little less jaded
about the presidency,
and who the president should be,
and the statesman who
should lead America.
And I just was horrified
that someone who hated
the place might lead it.
And that's, from
there I just remember
marching down to the
local Republican office.
I didn't even know
how to run for office.
I said, "I'm running
for something."
(laughing) That's how it went.
- (laughing) They said,
"We'll take that 6'8" guy,
and see if he can run,
let's see what happens.
- Yeah, well it-
- You know, it's funny,
'cause I know you know
my story obviously,
about coming from the left.
And I was on board
the Obama thing,
and I voted for him twice.
But I remember day
one of his presidency,
when Michelle Obama
said that thing about,
"This is the first day I've
ever been proud of America."
I remember suddenly being like,
"Whoa, what, whoa, what, huh?
How'd that happen?"
- Yeah.
It bothered me so much.
It made me political,
because like I said,
I wasn't even
active in politics.
I wasn't doing any of that.
I was working construction,
I just met my wife, so
I'm chasing all my money.
I'm spending all my money
chasing her around, Dave.
You know how it goes.
And I just wasn't,
I wasn't involved,
but the more I read
about this guy,
I thought to myself, "Wait,
this guy's gonna be the nominee?
What? This guy can't
be the president."
And look, the rest is history.
- So since the book is called
"The Anti-Communist Manifesto,"
and I'm sure many
people are familiar
with "The Communist Manifesto,"
first off, do you make a
distinction at this point,
is there an important
distinction to make
between socialist, communist,
and even Democrat at this point?
Like how would you
sort of line up
each one of those ideologies?
- Yeah, there's no
difference in any of them.
So there's no need,
there's no point
in making any
distinctions at all.
Because this is what we do,
and this is actually what
they do very, very well to us,
and then we oblige.
We stress because you
have a moral code, Dave.
Now I don't have much
of one, but I have some.
(Dave laughing)
But because of that,
there are things
we don't wanna be,
and things we don't wanna do.
Like, I don't want to be
a hypocrite or a liar.
I'm a bad person,
but I don't wanna be
accused of those things, right?
So what they will always do
is they'll always have you,
the communists these days,
will have you define things.
He'll never define
anything for you.
"Hey, what is social justice?
Hey, what does it mean?
How do we know we'll
have gotten to equity?
That's surely the goal, right?"
He'll never define
anything for you,
you can't get those definitions.
But he'll demand you
define everything.
"Well, it's actually
not socialism,
'cause if you look at the
dictionary definition,
that's that," that's how he
gets you every single time.
None of that matters.
Communism is just a
religion, that's all it is.
Communism, socialism,
now modern Democrats,
it's the religion
of the malcontent.
That's why it's taken
a different form,
every country it's ever
been put into place,
from the Soviets, it
was the urban poor.
They tried to do that in China,
and Mao said, "Nope,
you're stupid.
Our urban poor are
actually pretty happy here.
We have really
miserable rural poor.
So it's the rural
poor in China."
In America, it's not
any of that at all.
It's all cultural now,
'cause our urban poor
and our rural poor
had a great life,
and they couldn't
get traction here.
So they switched with
the Frankfurt school,
to all this cultural
Marxism stuff,
where, "Are you gay and
oppressed in this country?
Are you black and oppressed?
Are you a feminist and
oppressed, are you,"
just trying to find
whatever malcontented group
they could find out there to
try to burn the place down.
It's just the religion
of destruction.
It's not more
complicated than that.
- So is that really
what it boils down to,
that because we have some
code of ethics, let's say,
and some principles, and they
might be somewhat different,
but we're acting against
a bunch of people
who it seems to me their mission
is either only to burn it down,
maybe with a dash of
replace it with something,
but I'm actually not
even sure of that.
I think it's just
a burn it down.
And that we somehow, in
some ways it feels like
we can't win because they're
all in on destruction,
and it's much easier to
destroy than to create.
- No, no, yes and no, Dave,
I guess I'll put
it to you that way.
We can win, we can win,
good can defeat evil,
but only if good understands
it's fighting evil.
That's another reason
I wrote the book.
It's what we've
never done before.
Again, because you have
some sort of a moral code,
and especially because you
used to be on the left,
and you used to run
in those circles,
you undoubtedly will think about
individual friends you
have, a Democrat here,
a liberal there,
who you can talk to.
To this day, you
may talk to them,
you may break bread with
them, and think to yourself,
"Well that's, this
person may be misguided,
but he's certainly
not my enemy."
And that's fine when you
think about individuals,
but we're not dealing
with bad overall
when we deal with the movement,
this communist movement here
in America, really globally.
We're not dealing with bad,
we're dealing with evil.
And but we approach it like
we're dealing with bad.
Like, if we just
talk to 'em enough,
if I'm just
understanding enough,
"Hey, we both want
school shootings to stop,
so let's come to a compromise."
But what we've never understood
is they don't want
school shootings to stop.
And I know that sounds
like extreme to people,
but when Dave Rubin wakes up
and sees a school shooting,
his frickin' heart breaks,
and he's calling family
and friends, and,
"Did you see the kids,"
and how sad this is.
The communist doesn't
think like that at all.
Joe Biden gets together
with his staff,
that on the day of
a school shooting,
and there's not a single tear.
In fact most of them are happy.
"Hey, this is great, who died?
Oh, nice, it was black people?
Oh good, tell me the
shooter was white?
Oh yes, shooter was white.
Let's do a statement
out there, we'll visit,"
everything's an opportunity
to somebody without any
values at all, everything.
And it's hard to accept
that about your fellow man,
that that's what
you're dealing with.
And that's the struggle
with the right, right now,
how do we accept that?
'Cause that's what
we're dealing with.
- Okay, so how do
we accept that then?
Because I sense, and
you know, as you know,
I've been a very
vocal new Floridian,
I sense that the right
version of conservatism
is taking root here.
A piece that understands
when to use government,
what is true, what type of
leaders we want, et cetera.
I mean, is that the root
that we need the rest of
the country to go down?
Maybe that, well, I
made it 10 minutes in
without saying DeSantis.
- No, no, no, yes, that's
what we need to do.
We need to adjust our
mentality for ourselves,
and our leaders.
Like, you know, it's been
this way for most of my life,
where the right, when it comes
to something like a boycott,
it was the norm, Dave,
it was mainstream.
Not just from politicians,
from pundits to say things,
like, "Well, we don't do
that, that's not who we are.
Well, that's not who we are."
And then we woke up one day,
and Target's telling
your 13-year-old daughter
to chop her boobs off, and
we were shocked at that.
Well, why were we
shocked at that?
The corporate boardroom was
only ever getting pressure
from one direction.
The right has to understand
now that this whole philosophy
of bragging about not
using power is ridiculous.
If you have the
governorship, like DeSantis,
you use it, like DeSantis.
If you have numbers in
your local community,
you go take over
your school board,
and you make sure your
values are in your school,
you use power.
The communist is
still a minority,
but he understands
how to use power.
We will drive by the local
public library 1,000 times,
you, me, everybody, and
you won't even look at it,
unless you have kids.
It's a public library,
who gives a crap about it?
The communist drives
by the public library,
and he sees an
opportunity, he sees power.
Why are there child
drag shows going on
at your local public library?
Because you drove
by it 1,000 times,
and never thought about it,
and he drove by it
and he saw power.
That's why we must
adjust our mentality.
- Is that the beauty
of what's going on here
with Target and Bud
Light right now,
that it seems like, and again,
when I say conservative,
I just mean sort of the broad,
like, roughly sane people,
people who are somehow
connected to reality, let's say,
that bottom up they
were like, "All right,
no more Bud Light,
no more Target,"
and it's actually working,
meaning they weren't
fully waiting
for the top-down
version of all of this.
- Yeah, yeah, I think the
Target stuff, honestly,
I think the trans
stuff specifically,
the trans kids stuff,
I've made this argument,
I believe it might save the
United States of America,
and I really mean that,
'cause I just mentioned how
outnumbered the communists are,
and they are, but they've
been much more committed,
and they've been involved.
So you have all these
people on the right,
just kind of normal people,
"Ah, did you catch
the game last night?"
But didn't really
ever get involved.
And that lasted forever,
for the most part.
For the most part,
people don't care
what other people
do with their lives.
They really just don't.
And then all of a sudden,
normal person woke up one day,
and he found out,
"Wait a minute,
we're chopping
off boys' penises?
That's something that's
happening in regular,
that's happening in the country?
Wait, Disney wants
kids to do this?"
Normal guy woke up one
day, and all of a sudden,
there's a tranny on his Bud
Light, and now you woke him up.
And that was really what
we needed all along.
We needed that guy,
who shares our values,
to wake up and realize
we're dealing with a whole
different animal here.
And the second you
start attacking kids,
I'm hopeful that maybe
a line has been crossed
that now we're gonna
really start fighting back
with some teeth.
That's why you see
Target boycotts, and
Bud Light boycotts,
worked for the history
and right wing boycotts.
- So now that we're
seeing it from the people,
what do you make of
the set of Republicans
who've been pushing back
against some of this stuff?
So, you know, say Chris
Christie, Mike Pence,
the Republicans who are against
DeSantis going after Disney.
Nikki Haley, I was on
Megan Kelly's show,
who I absolutely adore,
she was kind of against it,
you know, that there's
this set of people
who are now like, "Oh, we don't
want to ever use government
to do things," even when, in
my view, it's extremely just,
and certainly within the
purview of government.
- Yeah, well I don't care for
Chris Christie or Mike Pence,
I adore Megan Kelly
just like you do.
But I'll say this, I
sympathize with that, Dave.
And this is why I
sympathize with it, I'm 41,
I'm not ancient, I know I'm
going bald, but I'm only 41.
But my entire life-
- You're a kid, man.
- Conservatism, or
being on the right,
or whatever that may
be, it has always been,
"Hey, this is all the
power we won't use.
Hey, this is how
limited our power is.
Hey, we won't use our power.
They will, 'cause they're
the bad guys, but we won't."
And so that mentality, that
mentality's been ingrained,
it's been beaten into
people on the right
for most of their lives.
If you're 60 years old
watching Dave Rubin right now,
that's all you've ever known.
If you read or paid
attention to right wing news,
and sources, that's
all it's ever been,
bragging about not using power.
So when you wake up one day,
and you walk into
that person's office,
and you tell them, "No, we
must use all the power we have,
or we're going to lose to
some subhuman savages,"
it's hard for that person
to just wake up one day,
and realize, "Oh my goodness,
we need to use power."
It'll be too far
for many people.
I understand that, it's
hard to change a mentality,
but the right needs an
entire mentality change.
- What do we do about
the set of people,
and it might be
half the country,
it might be more than
that are brainwashed and are
not gonna come around to this?
So, you know, like I
see you on Twitter,
I'm kind of in this camp too,
it's like we need some
separation from these people.
To me, if the DeSantis
thing doesn't work,
at what point are we the
United States of America,
if Cali wants to
go down that road,
and Florida wants to go
down the freedom road,
like what actually
is uniting us?
But we are still one
country, at least for now.
- Yeah, we're not
one country anymore.
Again, I don't
wanna be too jaded,
but I don't wanna be too
pie-in-the-sky either.
We're not one country anymore,
and we won't be one
country 100 years from now,
and we shouldn't be.
I say that and people get mad,
especially people on the right,
'cause people on the right
are actually patriotic.
Well understand, I
love my country too,
but we shouldn't be a nation.
The only point in coming
together and living as a people,
whether you are a tiny
tribe or a big country,
is for the protection
and prosperity
that living around
each other provide.
And you only get that if you
share some common values.
If I believe in being
left alone, Dave,
and you're my next door
neighbor in the tribe I live in,
and you believe every
day you should wake up,
and come poop in my living room,
well, we shouldn't be
next door neighbors.
It doesn't mean you're
wrong, I'm wrong,
we just have different
values, we need to be apart.
That's where we are now.
We are two different
countries at least,
and we're already separating.
People are migrating,
they're leaving California,
they're leaving New York,
they're going to Texas,
they're going to Florida,
they're going to Idaho.
People are separating,
as the blue states descend
into hell, and they will.
I mean, the people
don't even realize
how bad it'll get
in blue states.
Red states, people who
wanna live normal lives
will move to red states,
and how that final separation
comes, I'm worried about that,
but it's coming at some point.
- Do you think there is a rock
bottom for the blue states?
I mean, I was in San
Francisco last week,
and no matter how
many times I go there,
and trust me, I don't wanna go,
so it basically takes
a lot to get me there.
It is unbelievably horrible.
It is not an American city.
It should be the lead story
on every cable news
channel every night.
Of course it never is.
- You know, that actually
breaks my heart, Dave,
'cause unlike many
people, I love cities.
I love the country too,
I grew up in Montana,
I love 'em all,
but I love a city.
And I've heard, I never
got to go in its prime,
I heard San Francisco was, at
one point, the most beautiful
city in this country.
- Oh, it was.
- I've just heard
it was stunning.
And so I don't celebrate
when that stuff happens.
But to answer your question,
I view this as being
a spiritual war,
as much as anything else.
I've told many people, "I
don't care what you believe,
it's not my business."
But you have to look
at them and understand
you're dealing with evil forces.
And evil doesn't
have a bottom, Dave,
to answer your question.
I mean, bad does.
If you're a bad guy, if I'm
a bank robber for a living,
I may wake up tomorrow
morning, I very well may,
and say, "Dude, I've robbed
enough, it's too dangerous.
I don't feel right about it.
I'm gonna go get an
accounting job somewhere."
Bad might do that, but a
demon never wakes up one day
and says, "Man, you know, I'm
done with all this evil stuff.
I think we've gone
too far, guys.
The kid stuff is too far, I
think we should sit it out."
It only goes down from here
in those places, sadly.
- Right, so what do
you do for the people
that are not quite
at demon level,
that are just that
confused level, let's say?
You know, for the people
that are the self-avowed,
19-year-old communists of today,
that maybe we can do a
reclamation project on.
- Well, I think
they're gonna have
a very hard awakening
on their own,
and very sadly, Dave, they're
not going to listen to you.
They're going to listen to
the misery that comes one day.
If they would listen to you now,
they would wake up
and come out of it.
But that's not
generally how it's gone.
There are many, many,
many, many, many communists
in the Soviet Union who
found themselves slowly dying
in the Gulag system,
who woke up and realized
that they had served some
seriously evil people.
And that's kind of what
it takes to wake up
a lot of people who
get seduced by that.
It's easy for young people to
think they're being tolerant,
or nice, or, "I wanna be
loving," or something like that.
And then one day you wake up,
and you're stepping
on heroin needles,
and slipping on poop,
as you walk down the
sidewalk in San Francisco,
and you realize that maybe my
life that I was hoping for,
maybe I was sold
a bill of goods.
And it's gonna take that
level of misery for people.
That's why, look, as
much as it saddens me
that San Francisco's like that,
that New York's going this
way, Philly, these places,
as much as it saddens me
in a way, I celebrate it.
Not that I want
anyone to be hurt,
and raped, and murdered,
or anything like that,
but clearly people who
still vote Democrat,
they have not
experienced enough pain
from their voting choices yet.
And I don't want them
to experience more pain,
but obviously they're going to
have to experience more pain
before they wake up and start
changing their behavior.
So look, go ahead, loot the
next door in San Francisco.
I don't care.
Keep voting Democrat,
they'll keep doing it.
- Let's hit a couple
of the other big topics
of the day right now.
Are you, I would say,
let's say generally pleased
the way the mainstream media
seems to be collapsing?
It's pretty good
for guys like us.
I do think there's a
certain risk involved
when nobody believes
the same thing.
But it seems inevitable to me
that these guys are gonna
collapse at this point.
- Yeah, in a completely
poisonous institution,
that's a clear
and present danger
to the United States of America.
I think it's a great
thing it's collapsing.
I actually am not sure what
this is going to look like,
but gimme a second to
filibuster here, Dave.
I have this thing I
think about a lot,
where I think about society,
this is gonna come back
to the media thing,
it's like a big ball
of Play-Doh, right?
We all had Play-Doh
when I was a kid.
And then you have these
elites, the media people,
the politicians, the
professors, the entertainers.
They're a part of
the Play-Doh, right?
Well, because they're
evil, and horrible,
and corrupt, and they hate us,
they're kind of been separated.
So it's like they're this tumor
on the outside of
our ball of Play-Doh,
and they want to pull
us back with them
so they can continue to lead us.
But really everything they do
continues to violate trust.
And so instead,
they're just pulling
away, and away, and away,
and it's getting thinner,
and thinner, and thinner.
At some point in time,
that strain's gonna break.
And I don't know
what that looks like,
but when 60% of the country
thinks the FBI is a
criminal organization,
and that's where we're at,
people don't trust the media.
People don't trust the CDC.
Even five years ago,
if I told you the CDC,
even normal right wing guy-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, Dave, what
did they have to say?
That's really important,
now you hear CDC
go, "Oh, what are
they lying about now?"
How does that look for a nation
when all of its
institutions break away?
'Cause they clearly have no idea
how to earn that trust back,
and get back in the
ball of Play-Doh.
I don't know what
that looks like.
I can't imagine it's good,
but it's probably better
than the alternative.
- Isn't it kind of funny
what it does to guys like us?
Like people come up to me
when I go to the supermarket,
or go bowling, and they're like,
"Dave, you're the
only guy I trust."
And I'm always like, they
mean it as a compliment,
but I'm always like, "Shit,
we're in a lot of trouble."
- Yeah, yeah, I think
that a lot when people,
they'll thank me
for doing the show,
or thank me for
talking about this,
and I try to explain, I
mean, I do appreciate it,
but man, I'm an idiot.
If you're relying on me
to be the only one who
tells you the truth,
we are in very serious trouble.
There should be like a bunch
of very smart people out there
who bring this stuff
to you all the time,
and talk to you like
this all the time.
If it's me, that's not good.
(laughing) That's not good.
That's good for
us, I guess, David,
that's not good for the country,
which is what really matters.
- Yeah, well I'd like to think
that there's a whole slew
of us, but nonetheless,
it's like I would,
that's the funny thing,
I always say about
the mainstream media,
it's like, "You guys
don't have to be good.
Just don't be
endlessly horrible."
But let me ask
you something else
on just like the purely
political side of things.
You seem to be sort of where
I'm at in the DeSantis camp,
on what's going on with
him and Trump right now.
I supported Trump.
Every morning I wake
up, and I'm like,
"I hope he hasn't
posted anything today,"
'cause that way I won't
have to go after him,
because I don't wanna
have to go after him.
But if you attack Florida,
if you attack Kayleigh,
if you attack the
policy on COVID,
like all of the stuff,
it feels incumbent on
me to do something.
What's been your
policy on all this?
- My policy on it is
that I don't fall in
love with politicians.
I don't join anyone's team.
I don't, I'm not on team Trump,
I'm not on team DeSantis.
I want them both in the
primary to beat each other up,
'cause I believe that will
give us a better candidate.
What I've said is
I'm leaning towards
voting Ron DeSantis now,
because COVID lockdowns,
and COVID back stuff,
it's my biggest issue.
Other people have issues they
vote on, that's my issue.
I view that as being a crime
perpetrated against
the American people.
And right now I'm voting for
Ron DeSantis in the primary,
because Donald Trump won't
stop bragging about it.
He's either lying about it,
or he's bragging about it.
"We did everything perfectly,
the vax saved millions
of lives," these
things are not true.
And the American people
are owed a reckoning.
I'm not saying he has
to get on his knees
and beg for forgiveness,
but some sort of ownership.
Don't spit in my face.
Don't tell me it was great
when it wasn't great.
And don't tell me you didn't
do it when yes, you did.
I was alive, I wasn't
born yesterday.
As far as the, I saw that
Kayleigh McEnany stuff,
and stuff like that with Trump.
Look, this is the kind of
thing where you know what?
You ever known anybody who
really struggled with weight?
Dave, I know you have,
we all know someone
who struggles with
weight and they're fat.
And then they'll sleep in,
and then they'll wake up,
and their body will
hurt, and they slept in,
and they didn't sleep
well 'cause they're fat.
So instead that turns
into a fast food meal,
instead of a workout, and
then you feel like crap again.
And later on you might
as well just order a,
where things are bad,
but because they're bad,
things snowball and get
worse and worse and worse.
This is what happens,
this is what's happened
to Trump for a long time,
for four years, it's
happened to him.
The people around him are
really, really, really bad.
He, for whatever reason, the
guy's policies are great.
He's just cannot pick
personnel at all.
The people around him are awful.
They're losers and
scumbags and idiots.
But at the same time,
because they're losers,
and scumbags, and idiots,
and because Trump wakes
up and does things,
like give it to Kayleigh
McEnany both barrels,
he can't get good people.
All the people that will
want to work for him
are losers, and
scumbags, and idiots.
So you want Trump to have
good people around him
to implement good policy.
But because of stuff like that,
because he just doesn't seem
to wanna control himself
on social media, he ends up
alienating all the good people.
What, I mean, Kayleigh
McEnany was a star,
or whatever you think
about her personally,
I don't know her, so I'm
not friends with her,
so I don't care,
but she was awesome.
If that lady's getting
blasted both barrels,
what talented person's going
to work for Trump again?
And this is why, as I've heard
for months and months
and months now,
the talented people
are saying no,
they're being reached out
to and they're saying,
"No, I'm not interested."
And so it, like I said,
it makes it worse.
It only gets worse from here.
- Yeah, there's definitely
a self-fulfilling prophecy
element to it.
What about the Democrats?
I mean, we're gonna throw a guy
with dementia back up there.
The woman behind him, you know,
probably doesn't know
what two plus two is,
or would give you a very
convoluted explanation
on how there's multiple answers.
And then just beyond
that, I mean the bench is,
you know, you've got truly
a communist in Gavin.
The rest of them, it's just
such a freaking clown car.
Like there's just nothing left.
- There's nothing left,
and that's kind of
a sad place to be.
I don't know about you,
I would love the option
of voting for a Democrat.
- Of course.
- I can't stand Republicans,
I yell at Republicans as
much as I yell at Democrats.
But I can't vote for that,
what am I supposed to vote
for, child mutilation,
and an open border?
I can't vote for that.
There's no reason there,
there's no nothing.
It's all just march, just
burn it all down crap now.
So I can't vote for that.
So I'm stuck voting for
the frigging Republicans.
But Dave, I mean, look,
it's time to address the
voting in this country,
and the way it goes,
and the machine
the Democrats have
built over time,
decades, and
decades, and decades
of building up government
forces to aid them in this,
where now you can run a
president who has dementia
from his basement, never
holding a rally of any kind,
never really doing any
serious GO TV efforts,
nothing like that
from his basement.
Couple media interviews.
Remember when he got caught
with the prompt cards
behind the thing,
and now he's president of
the United States of America.
He can't talk, he can't think,
he can't stay up past
five in the evening.
The senator from Pennsylvania
is a freaking vegetable,
Senator Cucumber, he can't
talk, he's brain damaged.
He had a major stroke,
his brain is damaged.
He should be resting
and rehabbing.
He's a United States senator.
Dianne Feinstein
from California,
the truth is, there's no
more competency requirements
in this country
now that Democrats
have figured out how to chase
down the ballots they need.
And now that Democrat voters
cease any thought at all,
they just don't.
Like, we brought up New York
and San Francisco earlier,
these people will walk
through all this squalor,
and, "Oh look,
there's a homeless guy
doing heroin right there.
Oh, someone just
assaulted my wife.
Oh, it's election day?
Which Democrat are
we voting for today?"
(Dave laughing)
This doesn't go through
their head, it amazes me.
- I know, look at Chicago.
They got rid of Lori Lightfoot,
and then everyone was
excited for a half a minute,
and they voted in an even
more radical nut job.
I got one more for
you, Jesse Kelly,
'cause I know you're a busy man
with many shows to do today,
so I'm being respectful
of your time.
When people read the
anti-communist book,
will they feel at the
end that there is hope?
That is the question.
- Yes, yes.
It's not about, I separate
out every chapter,
and I tie up all kinds
of history into it,
of the different chapters,
of this is on the
education system,
this is on corporate
communism, this is on guns.
But every chapter has
action items in the end.
It's not just the yell and
scream, everything sucks.
It's this is the history
of it, this is the issue.
This is how we have to
attack it every single time.
I tried to lay it out as
kind of a how-to manual,
with steps we can take.
Plus there's some
humor in there as well.
- Jesse Kelly, the book is
"The Anti-Communist Manifesto."
The link is down below.
We shall continue this
in the digital ways
that we do these things, huh?
- Thank you, my brother,
I appreciate it, it's
at jessekellybook.com.
Thanks for having me on, man,
I appreciate you a lot, Dave.
- Good seeing you, man.
If you're looking for
more uncensored opinions
from today's thought leaders,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a wide variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.